[Music]
civilization to protect backwards when
the Muslims were thrown out in Spain in
your background are you Jew yes aha
you mind other Jewish do you know
historically that the Jewish not being
saved by the Muslims in Spain yashi's
then that is not necessarily now because
most of the people they don't know that
about this could you tell us a bit about
it so because they don't learn history
what happened exactly and they don't
bloody will read I'm sorry should read
go to Spain do they look at Seville do
they look at the Alhambra do they not
see the effect of Spanish architecture
of the Muslim architects southern France
is the same thing so basically the
Jewish that time they they they they
survive which we know today through the
Muslim umbrella and we started to have a
hard time in Europe when the Muslim
empire retreated most of the people they
don't know that's why we're going to put
this I think the Europeans down yeah
that's right you know why could you tell
us don't want to know it does the reason
over or maybe because of the history has
been hidden of them do you know they
were mostly members of the UK Parliament
at the time of Queen Victoria and Edward
the seventh they sat over here as free
people a lot of people don't know that
either
the Jew you look up under about
Maimonides he was the leading civil
servant of the Kahless in Spain he was
one of those strange fellows
it was a polymath okay was a
mathematician he was a doctor he was a
poet he was an astrologer you often
wonder why he had time to sleep sorry
you have a lot of knowledge Dumont asked
you how old are you if you don't mind
I'm old enough to be your grandfather I
can tell you a lot of historical
knowledge that's which is which is more
I'm 70 shakes in now how is it do you
have the honor to do you have a I have a
Koran oh that's good so I can't read in
Arabic of these reasons I have to read
it in English so do you have the English
version or yes so your advise people to
look to the Quran this work I read it I
read everything that's good that's good
that's good happy to meet you sir happy
to meet you too we appreciate your time
yeah and am I now a film star yeah am i
yeah how do you how do you regard
you know Islam in the Muslim world
nowadays it's been very negatively
stereotyped well look I'm actually
interestingly enough as an Orthodox Jew
a great champion of Islam the fact is
that the Jewish community has a real
debt to the Islamic community because
when we were kicked out of Catholic
Spain in 1492 we were kicked out of
Catholic Portugal I think in 1503 it was
the Muslims who took the Jews in that's
why their Jewish communities in the
Islamic world till this very day the
Islamic community the Jewish community
of Istanbul dates from then it was it
was specifically countries and not
beyond the Ottoman Empire where Jews
were tolerated and they were welcomed in
and they play they pay to jizya there
was a poll tax they paid but they were
never persecuted there wasn't the
Holocaust in the Islamic world the fact
is the Jews and Muslims have so much in
common
very often I meet Muslims here in the
United States and my first expression to
them is one of sympathy I honor you for
celebrating your faith